let me ask the ridiculous question
just in case who's satoshi nakamoto
is it you we don't know it's probably
not me because
i was um like
17 when satoshi mounted bitcoin
16. so unlikely and also i'm not really
a programmer
so um there's a lot of theories but
honestly it's one of the greatest
mysteries of all time
because even bitcoins that have been
around
since day one really you know
people that were around before bitcoin
came out they're on the mailing list
they were active in the cypherpunk
community
you ask them and they sincerely will not
know and they may not even have a good
guess
as to who satoshi is is it important to
know or is it like actually
important not to know do you think
that's a feature or bug that you we
don't know
some people don't like the uncertainty
especially you know folks on wall street
they really want to know
and uh if you read the coinbase s1 their
disclosure pre-ipo that's a risk factor
that satoshi could come back
so the the risk management crowd wants
to know
because they want to know if maybe
satoshi had you know
undesirable political opinions or
something that would forever taint the
project
do you think they were just trolling
with that risk with the
satoshi's identity being a risk factor
or is that like
actual like was there an actual meeting
and a discussion of that being a risk
factor
i think in the risk factor sections of
the prospectuses it's really just the
lawyers doing a total brain dump to
cover
absolutely everything they can think of
so it's just lawyers it's not like
uh you know it's like i think elon was
somewhere in the legal documents where
spacex
mentioned that like uh earth governments
have no jurisdiction on mars
like they threw that in there and it
feels like yeah that could be lawyers
but it could also just be elon trolling
yeah so i wonder if it's like the
coinbase folks trolling
or if uh i don't know if it's lawyers i
hope it's the trolling not the lawyers
the the coinbase leadership they're not
as big uh
trolls this elon is but uh i mean it's a
it's a risk
for sure from their perspective because
let's say satoshi returned
doesn't seem likely and let's say they
decided to spend all their coins
which also seems very unlikely um that's
you know
rumored to be or estimates have it at 1
to 1.2 million
bitcoin which is like 50
60 billion dollars worth so
some people consider that to be a risk
you think it's
uh you know this is almost like a topic
of leadership
it doesn't feel like anybody any one
person speaks for bitcoin
uh not there's not even like prominent
figures like you have for like ethereum
you have vitalik buterin
it doesn't there's a lot of like top
minds talking about it like yourself
but it's not like one or two do you
think again
is that a feature a bug like uh do you
think for effective
for bitcoin to effectively have a role
in um society that like is as large or
larger than
the dollar there needs to be like
leadership that represents it almost
like democratic kind of thing
well that's a real counterintuitive
point because most bitcoiners including
myself would say no the lack of
leadership is
a great quality to have because if you
have a charismatic leader and a
foundation or corporation that controls
it
maybe they can control the features of
the protocol and maybe they can
expropriate holders of the coin or
you know build in an endowment that pays
them off
and gives them privileged access to the
units of the coin for instance so
you know we call people that have
privileged access to the money spigot
cantillon insiders which is there's this
economist that pointed out that
as you know i think richard county on
that as money
enters the economy has an uneven flow
right so you see this in the last
last decade or so before that too
the consequence of money printing in
this country is people that own
financial assets
made a lot of money and people that
didn't didn't so you see that
cantelon insider cantelon outsider
effect
and it's the same with the
cryptocurrency in many other alternative
cryptocurrencies that do have these
corporate
entities or these leaders and ceos
they're able to make specific decisions
regarding
the protocol and the currency of the
asset the benefit themselves their
cronies etc
and that's not a good feature to have i
mean it does
grant you you know the ability to
orchestrate decisions in a faster and
more efficient way
but long term what you're trying to
optimize for if you're creating a money
is monetary credibility and soundness so
you don't really want it changing all
that often
and you don't want to have the
appearance of um
you know these elites that are engaging
in rent seeking or anything like that so
there's definitely people that are
influential in bitcoin there's core
developers that people listen to because
it's
i would say meritocracy largely and
they're sort of self-appointed high
priests of the protocol
i write a lot about bitcoin people
listen to me but it's a completely free
market
of ideas right i don't have any
authority within bitcoin whatsoever
i'm just a scribbler you know you use
the scribblers
so was aristotle uh socrates
i need you okay
you